ryan martin beautiful blake sexiest man
in the world all those things and yeah
she is the sexiest man
yeah
yeah he's doing well there that's a good
shot right there look at you look at you
beautiful and happy yeah so annoying
yeah
no but to cheer us up when you started
kind of being interested in girls you
weren't as that cool or smooth with it
no no no not at all i don't believe it
no no i really i went through puberty at
like 27.
this is a freak thing yeah it was not
good yeah
who's the girl who's the girl in school
the first the first girl
the first well i was obsessed with this
this girl uh uh fiona gorczynski um
she said and she used to actually she
used to take the bus the the the
opposite way of my actual home and i
would get on the bus just to sit next to
her wow for 45 minutes the wrong way oh
there's something wonderful about there
was something
when you're young it's so cute when
you're older it's just stalking
you're like on some kind of watch list
but i remember when i was i couldn't
have been more than i don't know 11
years old and i and i i was just about
to get off the bus because enough is
enough i'm about to enter like seattle
or something so
i'm starting to get off the bus and i
decided to like kind of hit her with
like this cool look or something like
this like one of these like real sort of
don johnson miami
[Laughter]
and i sort of delay a little too long
and the bus doors close on my backpack
with my backpack and the bus just starts
to leak
i'm sort of like
like banging on the side of the bus the
bus driver finally stops opens the door
let's releases my you know idiot bag
backpack and i i could never look at her
again
yeah that was terrible yeah she's
looking at you now
can you imagine she's like he's the guy
with the backpack
he's the idiot with the ren and stimpy
backpack
it's welcome back to everybody apart
from you jody yes never been here before
i feel like i won a competition
well i mean because it is incredible you
know because obviously everyone got to
know you and dr foster but then killing
eve at something a global superstar yeah
it's been a good year
someone has been binge watching
have you watched the whole thing i
haven't watched season two yet because
i've been traveling uh when it came out
i'm already into season two oh yeah i've
already seen he got one off but jodi and
i'm not gonna lie when i found out you
were on the show i was standing up and i
just actually fell to the floor i was so
excited that you were such a fan thank
you that's so surreal
have you watched killing eve i've
already apologized for not having
watched it
i said that we'd let him live yeah first
of all you can ask the questions later
yeah i've never seen the goonies what
and and we did a film together i think i
might have pretended that i had
oh i know is that really shocking to you
it is shocking only because i've met one
other person who hasn't seen or at least
admitted wow
[Applause]
actually a lot of people are lying
because that was like half yeah no these
two people not no idea no never seen
them
they've never seen this show they don't
know who anybody is
you should see the goonies you should
have some access to outside information
yeah
you should just go now and uh google it
yeah excuse me very good do you get this
recognized do you know who he is you
know you know
you do oh you're fine then you stay
and the whole thing that bill because
she is
quite an extreme character presumably
you get extreme reactions from fans and
things when you when you meet people in
the street yeah i mean
a lot of people just look at me and
think is it hair but i had one recently
that was really strange someone asked me
um for a photograph and i was like yeah
sure and was um posing for a photograph
and then she quietly just whispered in
my ear
will you strangle me
and i was
like mobile the sisters with me at the
time and she was like no
miss comey will not do that no
betty she does yeah
talking of air pumped up you get to wear
the suit yeah which is a nice you know
kind of like i'm wearing a suit yeah
yeah well it's like a big red body
condom yeah but yeah sure but call it a
suit whatever you want but josh like
that
it's really you that like hey hey hey
i'm really in the suit okay i'm sorry
you could like put the suit on sort of
like like
it's just a team of people to get that
thing on like i'm always like so
terrified i'll like throw up in the mask
or something you know all these weird oh
yeah one of those like scratches that
you just yeah no nothing there's nothing
that can't there's no space in that
thing at all when i put it on i can
actually taste my own genitals it's
disgusting
do they roll you in talc or something uh
i do that's just that's just when i get
home from my wife
you know there's something about him
that he oozes that he's worked out even
though he has a suit on and all that
when i went and did avengers you know i
saw those guys put on suits and i saw
underneath like i was like you're not
working out at all and i won't say who
it is
and they put on the suits and they
looked fantastic they looked amazing
whereas him his suit doesn't really have
any bumps and stuff that's not there so
i know that he's back in his thing
because he's kind of like the daniel
day-lewis of comedians you know what i'm
saying very method whereas me as a
50-year-old man who gets sore
i put myself through torture for you
and boy did it pay off it really did i
got shredded i know incredible it's
crazy and what was nice was you kept
your fans up to date you posted uh
videos of your of your workouts here's
one of the videos of you working out
[Applause]
[Music]
were you involved in that ryan no i had
no idea
no for sure you did because it was very
indirect you were in that bathroom admit
it i was i filmed it
that was me
did you run it past uh josh that you
were going to involve his his stepmom in
the movie oh yeah barbra streisand no no
i didn't talk to josh about that no idea
he just said yeah yeah and i was like no
you didn't yeah
i think he thought i was kidding i was
like no i did and then there was i can't
really talk about there was a point
where i heard the song can i say one
yeah the song coming out of your mouth
yeah the papa papa can you hear me right
coming out of your mouth
keep going no no i i
papa do you see me
it's like
can you find me
in the night
[Applause]
dental it's right you've seen yentl not
goonies come on
[Applause]
and the plane hadn't yet taken off and
the um
the the
woman who just had just gotten married
uh just became
violently and horribly ill on the plane
i mean it was not like a pretty little
like sick bag kind of thing it was just
like i'm going to paint with my organs
like was just crazy
and people were freaking out all over
the plane and
there so they brought a stretcher down
and they put her on the stretcher and
they're wheeling her away and like
the the uh her her new husband is just
kind of cruising along with the thing
and he sees me and he's like deadpool
no way high five and i and i
i'm like i don't what do you like what
has she got like what's happening
you know like you know like he's like
let's touch eyeballs
no no and by the way your wife is like
half dead
help her man
so it's just a very surreal moment i'm
i'm sure they're fine i'm sure they're
on their second anniversary now ryan the
thing about you growing up i love the
the you told stories about growing up
because your dad it was like he was
training you for paparazzi he was very
snap happy yeah he was i was actually
the saddest moment in our childhood and
these are uptown problems was when they
switched from film to digital because to
my father that was just like every day
was the lottery i mean it was amazing
because you could just take pictures and
pictures and pictures thousands of them
it could be like thousands of pictures
of just a meatloaf that's blurry and
what he would do is at the end of the
night he would email everyone in the
family all the all the photographs as
well yeah but the the thing is this is
back when like the internet was made of
a fax machine of wood like it was just
and then you would download all of these
things and like you like it was so much
material to download you'd feel like the
lights dim in your home like
this must be costing a fortune and i got
i used to say them i was like dad can
you stop you don't need to on every
phone like we don't need to see the
blurry photo of the ceiling you took
when you like just edit yourself never
did so after a while and i i i mean i
deeply regret this now as an adult male
i have deep regrets of what i did but i
would take the camera sometimes in the
middle of dinner and i'd just go in the
bathroom and i'd just i did just grab a
quick shot of my penis
and then he'd email it to everybody nana
and kathy uncle tim
uh
gramps got a few of those
they think it was his though um no i
well that was his concern which is what
actually in a weird way made the whole
thing work for me so after that he
became a strict editor so you'd get just
two lovely family photos at the end of
an evening not sixty thousand shots of a
of a you know mashed potato
yeah
no not a penis out of peanuts yeah
i thought you would say it looked like a
mashed potato and i was like
oh but actually very quickly before we
say another thing i should just say uh
if you are a zane malik fan i'm really
sorry
and he's not here
zane malek's really making me regret
this zayn malik tattoo i have on my back
he's making it difficult
ryan ryan treated when he heard the news
of the cancellation
zane isn't on the great norton show with
me anymore i'll still go but obviously i
got my lips done for nothing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i could feel josh falling deeper and
deeper there
that is like your honeymoon picture it
really is like it looks sort of like cgi
in the background like we didn't we
weren't actually outside we weren't
actually in yeah well like this morning
i mean i i told him this this morning i
wrote a text to him last night and i
said you know i've really had a good
time like these things can not be so fun
and then sometimes they can be fun and i
said you could have no idea
it was a love letter it was a lovely
love it was a very intimate love letter
that i felt really good about not only
how it was written but the heart behind
it and then this morning i went down to
the gym and the first person i see the
only person i see in the gym is him and
you want to do nothing but avoid the
person that you wrote the textbook
we both barely made eye contact
very awkward but you you had feelings
for ryan before you met ryan
are you telling me this or is this
something about you something you said
you said no i have said it i saw the
proposal and i have no shame in saying
that even though i saw it alone all
three
i times a fan wow i am a fan i just can
you not not wrap my head around you
sitting and watching the proposal
no no not at all
[Music]
i can see you watching and just being
like this guy no no no no i felt
that when i saw green lantern okay
ryan we don't think of canadians as
having accents and yet you do you've
lost your accent you would say yeah i've
i sort of trained myself out of it but
you know i go back home and it it pops
up again it's uh that's all i hear
that's all ottawa oh yeah
stay about uh it's a well in canada it's
a boat that's what i'm saying say it the
way you say what do you talk about what
are you talking about but it's all my
everything is i it's a bad word but i'm
sorry so you handle everything with
buddy
and is it something about the canadian
accent that makes you a really bad liar
um yeah well yeah we're not we're not
good at it lying or fighting really i
mean
that's all slappy
it's not very sexy
oh yeah yeah i was i i my wife is a
foodie she she loves these uh apple pies
that they make at this at this place in
vancouver where i grew up so we grabbed
a bunch of them and headed we were
driving back down to the states and we
were across the board you're not allowed
to cross the border with like that's
illegal right yeah
and this guy knew something was going on
and now we get up to the border crossing
yeah pie smokers
most like hollywood actress they have
like a kilo of cocaine in there
you know uh so
my voice always gets really high when
i'm when i'm like lying he was like he
got anything any fruit any vegetables
anything like that i was like no
oh
and he's basically he ages had me on the
hook and he looks at me and goes hey i
remember that you know that movie you
did that movie just friends and i was
like yeah yeah yeah he was like you know
that song at the end of it where you
sing this i swear by all for one and i
was like yeah he was like yeah go ahead
basically you're saying dance monkey
i bet you dance i
in dance by the next stop
[Music]